hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen any time
I put one of these episodes out and
people are like how did you not see that
it was running everyday on TV it's like
I don't know manage I never saw it
this though I feel like this I should a
cop at some point today I'm watching
It's a Wonderful Life I'm excited though
it's been a hot second since I've seen a
movie that I really loved and was like
very feel-good so I'm hoping that's this
I'm hoping this puts me super into the
holiday spirit and I'm very excited
[Music]
that was so good I always have it in my
mind that I'm not going to like older
films I don't know if this was remade
with color I'm sure it was at some point
but I watched it in black and white and
always so worried that I'm going to find
older films boring anything earlier than
the 80s I'm just like oh my god
do they have TV back then it's
interesting too that the setup is so
long in this movie it takes so long into
it until you get to the actual like plot
kind of of the film this poor guy George
Bailey goes there's so many trials and
tribulations and then you get to the end
- may the angel and it's like wow I mean
we have 20 minutes left this is so weird
what an odd way to do it and for some
reason it works for me mostly it's Jimmy
Stewart playing George Bailey he is so
good actually know someone named George
Bailey they were legends of the asphalt
they helped create a billion dollar
industry but one man was keeping it old
school this summer prepare hello hi John
Bailey how are you I had no idea you
were in it's a wonderful life and I love
your characters George Bailey and he's
uh he's great he's got a very distinct
voice like I always knew you had I just
had no idea no this is not it's John
Bailey I'm not George Bailey do you
think we're the same person I don't
really pay attention to names or faces
in these reaction videos or ever so I'm
gonna go ahead and finish up this review
but talk to you soon okay bye bye bye no
we're really good friends the true
standout started me though is Donna Reed
she is a queen in this film she
single-handedly saves the family
multiple times
she's a wonderful partner she
like a badass mother who's like
renovating their home and constantly
saving the talent our marriage and I
love her character the story takes place
and it's the life of George Bailey and
he's a wonderful wonderful human and
he's done incredible things for the town
that he lives in and it starts off and
he saves his brother single-handedly
from dying in this icy cold water in the
wintertime and it's just what a way to
start the film hi John I had no idea you
saved your little brother that's
incredible
I don't have a little brother we're not
the same person you know George Bailey
is fictional right I don't think you
understand film like at all
oh that's cool well I'll talk to you
soon bye then he's shown saving
someone's life because the pharmacist he
works for was gonna put poison on
accident in some of the capsules that he
was sending out George Bailey as a
character is a true hero John Bailey you
are a true hero really are we still
doing this okay all right he's your
buddy boo bye go to bed go to bed
then fast forwards and he's about to
embark on this big trip to go exploring
before he goes off to college and
there's a wonderful point where he sees
this lady in town who has a big crush on
him named violet and he's like violet
that's a nice dress and she's like what
this old thing well I only put it on and
I don't care what I look like
then she walks away and every single
person stares at her as she goes down
the street the true love of his life
even though he doesn't know it yet is
Mary played by Donna Reed it's of Mary
hatch and George Bailey go out on a date
and it's so cute it sparks the romance
she's so head over heels for him and I
just love what he says to her about the
moon hole
hey John pickles jeez what is it you
want Tamara is there any way that you
could you the moon monologue that you
say to marry action film I would love it
it's my favorite part
what do you want you want the moon say
the word no throw a lasso around and
pull it down for you hey that's a good
idea
I'll give you the moon Tamara Merry
Christmas Bedford Falls alright ok
goodbye George Bailey oh no George's dad
died oh no he gave up his Europe trip
although he even College - oh no Mary's
back and he's not calling her she has
the painting of the moon and the lasso
and she has the song they were singing
on their first date playing and he
doesn't appreciate any of it the sexual
tension in the telephone scene oh my god
I could watch that to put myself in the
mood every night it is that well oh JK
he's so mad oh JK he's kissing her
Oh JK they got married oh then I wrote
okay well Mary just gave all of our
honeymoon money for the town selfless
Queen
George Bailey didn't marry her I would
this is when things really start ramping
up you find out that uncle Billy has
lost his name uncle Billy that's a
terrible name uncle Billy has lost
$8,000 and the bank is now that's like
all of the money that the bank has and
everyone's gonna like go to jail and
lose their homes and everything is trash
but uncle Billy has a ton of animals
he's a pet squirrel and I think that's
pretty dope so George is super stressed
about it he's such a good guy who's done
everything by the rules everything by
the book and he ends up very drunk and
then he ends up on the side of the
bridge where he's about to jump to his
death it's actually a moment that really
touched me it just shows how you can
really get so frantic about something
care so much about something and feel so
helpless with it it felt so honest and
true and I was watching it just like
tearing up because this guy is like he's
gonna jump off this bridge and it's so
well acted and the story made so much
sense they built it up with so much time
and it felt right that it's just I mean
oh my god but then clearance jumps and
he goes and he helps clearance instead
and clearance is a Christmas spirit
ghost or like a guardian angel whatever
you got man but clearances clearance is
also dope he's a dope a lot that was a
terrible sentence that's not what I
meant
I mean I'm using the word dope a lot of
not using dope George wishes that he had
never been born
and Clarence proceeds to show him what
the town and everyone else's life would
be like if he hadn't been born a lot of
things are different the name of the
town a couple people had died I think
people weren't around anymore the
pharmacist he had held his brother had
died just everything was way different
his mom was sad and the funniest thing
to me was when he went to Claire and
then he's like where's Mary what
happened to Mary who cleared the sight
well you're not gonna want to hear this
she's like gentlemen she's an old mate
she never married she works
No just take me back please take me back
I need my my family and on blah blah
blah blah and it was just the most
incredible acting he sees Mary and
that's just when like water works and
she just saves the day again the whole
town comes they all celebrate
they've way more money than they need
his brother comes home from war he's a
war hero and it just ends in the most
beautiful stunning way also Bert and
Ernie were this I was reading the
predictions right now for this and I saw
a lot of you are saying that you haven't
seen it either definitely see this who
am I to tell you to see something but
definitely if you can this holiday
season watch this movie you'll cry
prediction over yeah so many people
predicted correctly that I was going to
cry
you'll be singing Buffalo gals won't you
come out tonight come out tonight thank
you so much for watching this you guys
and whether you celebrate Christmas or
Hanukkah or Kwanzaa or just sitting on
your couch drinking a beer Happy
Holidays for me I will see you all next
week again all right damn right this is
getting old oh my god I'm Tyra I didn't
like Scrooge I don't like cats where's
Mike leave me alone
[Music]
[Applause]
Merry Christmas
you